Moana crack sometimes I hope you
You're wrongTell me what to do.
The Go From Here becomesNot improving the
project.
ButActively working on new projects.
So that I can uncover the edge cases
When and when I say edge cases I really
refer to the flaws of the project
So that we can address them so they're no
longer flowsAnd over time.
And that's why we call it a dreamBecause
over time the dream is that it will be
perfect.
But we know it perfect isPerfect is in every
evolving.
Unnecessary creation from HumanPerception of
thought.
There's never perfect
Instead of perfection we just going to aim
to be the best
And when you when you walking on the moon
and planting your flag on a whole new
framework and a whole new system that you
created yourself
It's kind of easy to be first
I would argue my bad brotherI would argue
that.
My biggest hurdle now is the fact that I am
Loss for project ideas I literally spent all
day today trying to figure out what I wanted
to create and I came home
And no clue got on started screaming talking
to myself
Baby surgery
FlashTo make a shower.
That sound like highball
And whoever catch the ball got a taco get a
tackle
No one was fighting today
Nothing is perfect it's always something you
put today better so I asked him to your tea
I was like you know my personal right no I
have a website that you can put on and has a
chat hey I like you I said
Basically still your son but yeahSay yeah I
know what you're talking about cursive I
would code editor.
Kind of like BS oh that's what I meant you
kind of like me
Said I wouldn't say it's so much time but
more like it feel to pull a platform around
using AI for coding expensively where areas
I can flips across clothing writing
brainstorming and more
Cursor super focused on developers I'm more
liking generalGeneral purpose.
Right now or you just people
Is there anything you think you need to
upgrade
Awesome I know ones that we use so I'm going
to look out
The more up-to-date facts and context
awareness why I can sound confident about
things that change recent benefit you are
outdated answers better help returning them
Deeper multi-file and environment where
coding why editing one file Snippets is it
isn't enough for real apps benefit I'll help
manage cool repo's rentals just project
structure changes
Safer cleaner code execution and debug into
this why currently there is limited Direct
Execution or readReprod. Free product.
R e p r o d u c i b l e
Sorry reproducible environment control
Benefit is I could run your test so it's
traces and produce runnable patches
Another one it was fun that I saw it
It was something with the memories it could
hold it was wishing that it could hold
longer memories and remember you know how
sometimes your stuff
Longer context windows
Longer more reliable conversation memory why
I forget longer trust for earlier contacts
sometimes and if it feel repeats more
OnMore continuous.
Continuity
Right
Now
Yeah
I was very interested so I was listening and
you know the crazy thing Ariel
I was doing some dumb stuff like that
earlier too except not this version right
For whatever reason I wanted to know
What did they do before the tournament cuz
you know everything is a computer program
right
What did they doTo program the first
computer.
But did it already come loadedDid they find
it. Well it turns out.
They didThey used to have to plug up a whole
bunch of switches.
Yes sirWhat's today. What's today. Wait.
Do you have a change of clothes or you going
to wear the clothes you been wearing for the
last weekAnd are you going to go in there
with your hair looking like don't nobody
care about it.
And you went over there with no shoes noAre
you trying to make us look bummy.
I don't know
Bubble Guppies
I know
Hello
Next weekend
I ever do it
Got you
Into whatNo.
The ARs Advance rifle bullets
Damn I think that's the ones you turn into
theThe rifle.
When you bring the bullets
Well I was just about to say that that whole
head like 1600
Yeah that way you ain't got to play the 10
bears attack you game today but they can't
smash through the the
Through the metal detectors I mean the metal
Billboards you could just build yourself up
KnowYeah that's going to make it.
Yeah that changing things
See my dumbass
Set up my truck
And make sure you say make sure you make it
safe some kind of way
I'm not 100% on that
But I know it's something it's either a
sleeping bag or the twin bed I know I see
that sleeping bag bear the twin bed one of
them say
S Jennifer
Is broccoli doesn't yes or noCuz his mom
said.
If not it wouldn't
Not right now
1 8 0 6 3 3 6 9 1 2 2
You have your buddy name wrong
Much
And Young
Bbr
Mom's number areThis is mom's number or.
Hey Siri call BigTJ.
Hey Siri call Big TJBabe so I was right.
I was making the bedMaking the bed crap.
In the bed but last time
You know you might have a little mechanism
Right rightRight.
Yeah yeahI can come back to here.
Bet no more are youDon't get on now.
All right
I would say I'm impressed
But you could do betterI know what you're
capable of.
Is it supposed to be Moon I thought it was
supposed to be Saturn
Way
This might be your best workThe Snowman.
With the straw cat bro in space bro I know
you was on some shit when you was going to
tell me y'all see the Snowman you see the
nose
You don't see the smile let me chill then
don't you see the snowman Do you see the
Snowman
Things people see and you see the nose right
there and then you see his eyes
All right you see the smile
No oh okay let me snowball
Right right now
Yeah I thought that it is flood up in the
sky when all the way up there and it was
yeah that's what I thought and then I saw a
moon
I saw a moon at first and I found in his
oldest guy so that's
Yeah I hear youI'm done looking at this.
It's a horrible moon but it's a pretty
decent snowman I would flip it upside down
if I was you
I'm just saying
You can go Full Throttle with the hat thanks
Booty bitches with the hat all the estimate
Yes so you definitely see what I was talking
about now
I'm just saying if you take it to the art
show and they not fucking with it right
Turn it upside down to throw it out there
Like I said with my professional art
experience and I have an art class ever
I would suggest hitting the undo button back
to the Clean Slate starting over throwing it
away
But if you decide to continue with the
Snowman right
If you decide to continue with the Snowman
Exactly
Exactly cash that's all that's all I need
that's all I need to say right now that's
all I never need to be said
You don't forget to let her in that see you
later in that door not now she feeling
herself now I got to turn look see I would
fucking with tears but let me rotate
Oh the first thing I thought when I came
this direction was The Nutty Professor who
was that let's play Let's play Jeopardy okay
who was that they got slapped in the God
damn but piano
Oh RichieDave Chappelle.
That was Dave Chappelle who was Dave
Chappelle
Second oneWho was.
Who was our neighbors older sister
Another question immediately
Not even
I didn't answer yeah yeah that's what she
look like
You leave him alone
I'm totally catching up to your High Sports
Harley
Quinn
Where is Austin Texas
Park I want to know if Direction
Are you sure
But that's the best of the chicken
Why why I'm going to put a line right there
I understand
Never ever seen
The circular windowWe're talking. A window
in Frozen.
Window to the window you talking about
With the Crossing with the Crossing
I thought Russ said he's going to call me
when you ready
Didn't sleep
Stupid
Okay okay no you know what
Your perception and everything I was just
asking questionsI.
Fucking hit Marcus I would buy that shit
Right now
On the mother fucking members file
I remember this park
We're already done today
Inside a phone
Oh
If I feel like this talking about
Itself
No
Why the fuck did you come out with your
parents are gone
Erica birthday
Mommy
Chicago coach
I don't realize that when he touches it to
me Mommy
I know what he said he said handle my
lifeInspect me.
That's right what happenedOkay so basically.
Kakashi told them the question
So you know Naruto going to find one on one
like a dummy but he said to you soon Kakashi
used it on him and disappeared in the tree
He dropped the bill left on the floor with
the truck turned around and was about to
figure out the Bell but it ended up in the
traffic report
Kakashi came and got the bill while I know
what you want to stop sausage
Sasuke came and he threw the littleEyes.
Ain't no way he's shooting level
S
All right bro I replay repeat
Are you
Maybe I don't know are you going to stay
still next episode
You probably going to be in love with the
shower
Get back to Naruto never give up he already
got that he already got that same kind of
spirit that like if you like those kind of
stories that's what anime is all about some
kind of somebody who never gives up no
matter how bad again
And if you like that then you going to like
animeIf not then. Find our tumor and
Thunderman.
And they got that too
I think I watch them and you just want to
see the bloody Glory stuff like whatever you
like that guy